jean-luc pense à ta patrie quand ça ta
famille pense à tes amis et pense
surtout à ton cacher car bien entendu si
on quitte le plateau un peu penser à
tout ça aussi alors bien sûr si vous
quittez le fath aux échos c'est bien sûr
c'est caduc un haut niveau de l'hôtel
on a fait la moitié des missions peuvent
envoyer des gens la moitié qui donne
pourquoi jean-pierre il va rester là il
est trop près manon massé attention
c'est parti
attention 3-2 un tout bon soir ça va
mieux ça va bien vous voilà ça va très
très bien de ce monde hubert cette année
je n'y vais jamais jamais de sport
d'hiver de n'est pas ça je n'aime pas le
second préférait les studio théâtre le
théâtre le carrousel et bien qu'un
j'adorerais jouer un jeu télévisé
calme-toi jean-pierre un jeu télévisé
revêtir fait j'ai déjà participé deux
trois fois je vous ai fait j'ai fait le
juge les frais de licques juste prix
mais je suis surpris oui
[Applaudissements]